حكم بحبس شاب سته اشهر بسبب قطه فما القصه
قطه لا يتجاوز عمرها 3 شهور دخلت مطعم
بحثا عن طعام من شده الجوع فوقعت في يد
عامل بالمطعم القاها امام سياره ربع نقل
مما ادى الى مصرعها في الحال
[موسيقى]
انتشرت الروايه على مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي وبعد مطالبات كثيره بغلق المطعم
ومقاطعته كان رد المطعم بان ده حدث فردي
لا يمثلهم وانهم هيراجعوا بروتوكولاتهم
واجراءاتهم التدريبيه للفريق للعنايه
بالحيوانات
[موسيقى]
الرد ده ما كانش كافي علشان القصه تتقفل
حيث تقدمت مندوبه باحدى جمعيات الرفق
بالحيوان ببلاغ ضد العامل بالمطعم
[موسيقى]
واثبت تفريغ الكاميرات وشهاده الشهود
اعتداء العامل على القطه بالفعل وقضت
محكمه جنح عابدين بمعاقبه المتهم بالحبس
سته اشهر للتهاموا بقتل قطه عمدا
وده مش الحادث الوحيد خلال الفتره دي اللي
يتعاقد فيها متهم لاعتداء على قطه
فالداخليه رصدت استغاثه من بعض المواطنين
عبر مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي ضد شخص نشر
مقطع فيديو وهو يعذب قطه على تطبيق تيك
توك وحمل المقطع عبارات عنيفه يهدد فيها
القطه ويتواعد لها
الاجنبيه كل الناس اللي ما عجبهاش الحور
بتاع القط ده
من كل ناحيه ومتروق
وتبين انه عامل باحد المقاهي واقر بارتكاب
الواقع على سبيل المزاح فامرت النيابه
العامه بالتحقيق معه واتخاذ الاجراءات
اللازمه